that's limbani the chimpanzee who wasn't  able to contain his excitement when he  was recently reunited with the couple  who helped save his life he jumped into  his old caregiver Jorge's arms and gave  him a huge hug the pair met nearly two  years ago when limbani was born Jorge  and his wife Tanya gave the temple  around-the-clock care for the first few  months of his life conservationists at  the zoological Wildlife Foundation of  Miami say limbani greets them like this  every time he sees that's a nice deep  hug that is that is the very definition  you hug yeah that's what you call  jumping for joy kids see that when you  come home north I started coming up and  down yeah jumping into your arms but  then the way he reached for the mob  because the mother rejected the little  chimp that's right after the humans have  been working with mom rejected and then  they took him right back again